when in your opinion gentlemen do you
want to take it around you know behind
the back of the bar and just end it
and leave it it's not worth trying to
fix it because it's already broken
day one day one as soon as you have that
feeling
as soon as you have that feeling and
then well you know how long when like
the persians go to war and sparta
whatever and they say
you're dead today and you go fight to
stay alive
it's that approach so yeah it's dead
already she can win
she can win you back for the second time
but you got to take the approach that
it's already over
and you're just using a training partner
you've written some
articles or an essay ryan on like steps
to try to regain the frame and that's
like the starting point too isn't it
just
consider it that that's going to be book
two yeah first step it's the video
operations scorched earth i've had
essays and that on it before too but the
best ones
because otherwise what happens and i
know i'm kind of disjointed here i
haven't really thought this through is
like a coherent piece yet
but initially what happens is guys will
sign on they'll type into google my wife
won't [ __ ] me whatever
and then they get here and then the guys
start talking about things like dread
you know working out building boundaries
a lot of the chasing excellent stuff you
say overlaps a hell of a mount with it
which is awesome
and then two years into it they realized
because they were just doing it to win
their wife back
and the last thing their wife wants is
that kind of pressure
it's like when you take a girl out on a
great date and then she like
balks at the idea of putting out because
now she thinks you're entitled to it or
something like that
and then guys realize after two years
well i've been doing this all for her
and she completely nukes it and then
they realize
it's a waste of time if you're not doing
it for yourself and to save yourself two
years of hassle just assume
your wife is dead to you you're
basically working so that you never make
this mistake
again and she has until you're done and
ready to hopefully win you back
and if she doesn't then the plan is
already there that makes sense i agree
with that
i agree with that i mean i think that um
it's
it's the basic thing is you if you you
have to understand how to have frame to
begin with and somebody got into this
relationship without that
so you know all you're doing is working
on yourself and rebuilding yourself at
first
in order to and then learning what frame
looks like and how i would have that
and then she either buys into that or
not and then you start taking steps
basically to exit the relationship
but i always recommend if guys are under
stand frame and and they get into a
long-term relationship
that you always have the exit strategy
in mind
it's part of leadership it's part of
planning for anything
and maybe i think a little bit more too
mission focused right with military
stuff
but you always have that though you
always have your exit strategy
what does it look like but here's why
you want that it's not
because you're focused on that and
trying to end the relationship all the
time
it's because when guys don't have the
exit strategy in mind
then they're fearful they're fearful of
the unknown they don't know what that
looks like i've had a lot of guys come
into consultations they're married
they don't have a prenup they don't know
what it looks like you know i haven't
talked to an attorney yet they don't
know what it would look like
in that divorce and so they're afraid to
get their balls back they're afraid to
execute
standards and boundaries and start to
get
that frame with themselves like they
they lost frame in a relationship
they probably didn't have frame with
themselves you know what i mean
and so like you know they're afraid to
do that though because they don't know
what the exit looks like so when you
start off
it doesn't matter whether you're
cohabitating like ryan and i both have
cohabitating ltrs
rosemary richard and not what's that
you go and you cohabitate he goes and
he's married
and then and then rich and then rich you
know you don't cohabitate but whatever
that looks like you know what the exit
looks like then you're not fearful when
you execute
the strategy that you need to execute to
either get yourself back
get the relationship back or end it
whichever it turns out you know
what's your take rollo when it comes to
you know this is
this is the final straw you know we've
crossed the last line in the sand
when does that show up for you all right
so i i'm going to i'll tell you what my
personal
personally what i think and then i will
also tell you what i have learned from
experience from working with guys who
are like
in their like 60s and in some cases even
70s
uh getting into that point like just as
what paul was just saying a second ago
is you get kind of um get used to you
got accommodated to a lifestyle and you
you'd be surprised what you
like anything can can become normal and
especially when you are in a state of
necessity and i think that's the first
thing that guys need to
assess i if you've read my first book
you already understand this i've said
this but
in uh was iron rule of tomasi number one
you know frame is everything
and the frame that you enter into that
relationship with is going to set the
tone if nothing else i mean i'm saying
it's
it's immutable but i'm just saying it
will set the tone for your relationship
so
what you will tolerate while you are
single you will more than tolerate when
you are
when you're locked in and you're
committed to that so i don't think
enough guys think about that
first off because that has a lot to do
with like uh
setting boundaries and i i get into this
conversation sometimes with
i think with ryan a couple times as well
is i'm i'm the demonstrate
do not explicate guy and i i get to a
point where
i have to it's not so much the behavior
as it is the motivation for that
behavior
so when she is crossing boundaries
whatever those happen to be
it is much better to demonstrate that
that was a boundary you crossed it and
these are the consequences of it instead
of delivering an ultimatum which is what
most guys will do
when most got when guys get into a
relationship like i said they will take
and tolerate things that they would
never have tolerated before or even like
from their best friend
they would like come to bla punch a
friend in the face for some of the stuff
that you
you're willing to tolerate when you're
in a relationship because most guys
enter into a relationship when they're
necess and
they go in with a scarcity mentality and
so
the idea of rocking the boat or
experimenting or like uh even uh i had
this
conversation with sterling cooper
because sterling was talking about how
to have better sex how to get your wife
to have sex with you and how to
like sex her up the proper you know porn
star way i guess
and he told me the same thing i hear
from a lot of other guys which is i
could never do that i don't want to
experiment because if i upset the boat
then the boat will
sink it'll capsize if i try to do those
things
that when you get into that situation
you're kind of you're kind of lost
so you have to start with the as as paul
was saying and ryan was saying you have
to start with the ending in mind
so what is it that you're what is your
predominant character going to be what
is are you going to be predominantly
alpha do you have a frame into which she
wants to enter
into and what are what
what what do you want out of that like
genuine desire is something
that i definitely want out of all my
relationships and i learned that the
hard way
by tolerating stuff by again i i came to
this knowledge not because i was perfect
at it but because i screwed it all up at
one point
and uh and learned what it was that i
was what i was doing
i also learned that when i didn't care
that's when women came around i talked
about this on sunday on my sunday show
is when i started making myself my
mental point of origin and i didn't have
a word for it back then but when i
started
focusing on the things that i wanted to
do and that was my
my main like almost tunnel vision focus
that's when i found that women found me
the most attractive
when i wanted to be a rock star in in
1989 right when when i was when i was
working towards that and having a good
time and i was only focusing on what i
wanted to do that's when i suddenly
like guys will say this when you're just
ignore the girls and they'll come and
they'll show up
and in a way it's kind of true but it's
because you're focusing on something
else and you're creating this world into
which they want to enter
into instead of you being necessary and
finding the girlfriend and going oh
you're the best one i've ever had i'll
never find a girl like you he'll never
if you can break out of that mentality
before you get into
a relationship and then realize what it
is that you are willing to tolerate and
what you will not
tolerate that's when you can start to
have at least a mature
relationship
you